je vais me taper dans un ballon j'aime
courir après un ballon j'aime bien le
sport l'équipe puis football par-dessus
tubes dans les années 70 le football se
conjugue aussi au féminin
fraîchement reconnue par la fédération
la discipline attire quelques jeunes
femmes et je sens que j'ai le plus beau
dans la peau ça là c'est autre chose
c'est c'est la notation il a d'autres
s'ils basket pourquoi pas le football
après ton des femmes qui jouent au foot
des ovnis à l'époque mais l'engouement
est bien là entre 1970 et 1978 le nombre
de licenciés ne cesse de grimper passant
de 1800 à près de 12 millions pour le
joueur professionnel michel hidalgo plus
de doute le foot féminin a de l'avenir
michel hidalgo est ce que le football
féminin est devenu plus qu'une curiosité
certainement et comme vous avez dit
exactement de mots c'était notre
sentiment au départ de ce football et
maintenant c'est devenu une réalité
puisque de plus en plus les jeunes
filles et prouve ce besoin d'avoir ce
sport de plein air où elles peuvent
s'ébattre
encore sur une pelouse mais dans cette
discipline les préjugés ont la vie dure
les joueuses attise la curiosité des
journalistes qui n'ont alors qu'une
question à la bouche est-ce que vous
pensez que le football est compatible
avec l'évanouissement notre féminité
bien sûr est-ce que vous pensez que le
football est compatible avec
l'épanouissement de votre féminité oui
absolument oui oh oui je me semble que
toutes les filles devraient faire
football c'est un sport comme les autres
l'idée va faire son chemin le nombre de
licenciés grimpe encore pour atteindre
près de 35000 en 1999 la coupe du monde
98 en france contribué à cette envolée
certains clubs était même un peu dépassé
il ya une demande qui actuellement n'est
pas suivi par un manque de structures au
niveau des clubs féminins et qui ne sont
pas assez représentée au niveau des
différentes régions dans les années 2000
les fiv ont continué d'investir les
terrains de foot en 2005 la fff compte à
plus de cinquante mille licenciés elles
sont près de 198 milles aujourd'hui et
depuis les années 70 l'engouement n'a
pas changé dans le foot on peut marquer
on peut faire des célébrations que
surtout gâche vous gagner beaucoup
d'argent c'est ce que ça existe et
d'abord pour les garçons que et fine à
répandre à dijon la fédération espère
passer le cap des 250 mille licenciés
d'ici 2025 c'est encore très loin du
foot masculin qui compte près de 2
millions de licenciés
[Musique]